a forest of umbrella thorn acacia trees
in northern Tanzania provide shelter and
sustenance for a wealth of animals in
this crowded paradise property is hotly
contested at all levels mail or hala
eager to challenge for a territory build
up strength by sparring the strongest
male Impala urges females to sample the
trees in his exclusive territory teenage
sons are not welcome
the male's breeding success depends on
stamina and the quality of food in his
catch the better the local mania the
longer the females stay impalas must
nibble because large Thor and stop them
from grabbing mouthfuls and thorns are
not the only danger cheetahs are
masterful hunters but an impala herd has
many eyes with the cheetah spotted the
herd burns and jumps away Impala can
leap 9 feet in the air to escape
predators once the danger has passed the
impaler return and renew their struggles
for territory